it's great to be joined today by Cody
Rosenfield who's an advocate and
independent analyst who's been
investigating oil companies that
manipulate gasoline and oil prices he's
currently working with the Coalition for
clean air a Cody it's great to have you
let's start sort of basic I mean I think
that a lot of people generally have this
understanding that as the price of oil
herbs and flows on some sort of a delay
the price of gasoline that we put in our
cars sort of follows that a band flow is
that true is it that simple how are the
prices of oil and gas determined well
thank you for having me that's the right
question to start with
gasoline prices are absolutely tied to
oil prices but what what I end up seeing
is places with market power problems
places where there are too few oil
companies with too much power in the
market that's where it starts to get a
little strange so there will be an
increase in oil price but the gasoline
price will jump exceptionally more or
there'll or for example oil prices will
drop and there will be no impact on the
gasoline price so it actually kind of
depends on which market you're looking
at but there are many markets in the
United States where gasoline prices are
almost completely divorced from the oil
prices that they're supposed to be
related to to get this part out of the
way first and we'll sort of work up the
chain does the or how much does the
local gas station decide in terms of the
gasoline price is it on the matter of a
couple of cents and basically they've
got a small markup on a market that they
really don't have any influence on or as
you know how they're there are certainly
gas stations that are known as always
the most expensive or always the
cheapest but how much of that
variability is really being determined
by the gas station well actually very
little of the station owner has very
little power to set a price when when
you're a gas station owner especially
under a branded contract so if you if
you own a exxon mode you know a Mobil
station or a BP station you have very
little ability to choose what your price
is you're given a cost that you're gonna
pay the oil company to receive gasoline
and you have to stay within a very small
boundary of what
is you're allowed to charge or else the
company that's providing you the
gasoline will actually start to punish
you and charge you higher prices so most
of the actual pricing problems don't
come from the stations they come from
the companies selling to the stations
and an important part of this to
remember is that the prices that you see
that US consumers pay those are almost
completely unregulated a gas station
across the street from you could decide
to choose to charge $12 per gallon it
wouldn't work very well but they could
do it
where the regulations actually kick in
are on the wholesale markets and the
sales from those oil companies to the
gas stations good so let's now dig into
the different factors that allow the oil
companies to manipulate the prices that
they charge and are ultimately paid yeah
absolutely there's a number of ways that
it happens and it like I said earlier it
starts mostly with a market power
problem so for example in California we
have more oil companies that control
about 80% of the gasoline in the state
and California is not a market to sneeze
at if you look at gasoline markets of
the world California is the third
largest gasoline market after the United
States as a whole and then China so when
we're talking about small increases in
gas prices in a place like California
we're talking about essentially the
largest regional gasoline market in the
world and billions of dollars per month
that are being accrued by these oil
companies so it starts usually with
there being too few companies and then
from there there are a number of tactics
they can use from manipulating refinery
schedules when they're going online and
offline all the way to ships being
parked offshore and intentionally
confusing traders in that market to
cause the price either to raise or lower
yet the ships parked offshore to me was
reminiscent of what's going on in the
diamond industry and I've my audience
knows I am significantly opposed to the
entire practices of the diamond industry
and this idea that at least part of why
there's an argument to be made for the
high cost of diamonds is limited supply
but that's an hour
officially limited supply that we know
we know there are significant amounts of
diamonds that are just kept sort of
outside of the known or at least
quantifiable supply that am I wrong that
that's very similar to what's going on
with oil no it's absolutely similar
there's a there's a monopoly in the
diamond industry and that's why diamonds
are worth anything more than another
stone but with oil oil is similar in
that it also very naturally draws market
power and monopoly problems it's not a
coincidence that through the history of
oil there's always been some giant
player trying to change prices whether
it was Standard Oil or whether it's OPEC
today so just like diamonds
it's a these types of commodities if you
control the infrastructure you can
essentially it's very hard to stop
certain companies from getting too much
control and being able to essentially
set prices that's a very good example
with the diamond industry so as far as
it let's take an industry like the
airline industry right that really is is
directly impacted by the cost of jet
fuel which of course is derived from oil
there's sometimes the perception from
the air traveler that as the price of
oil and jet fuel goes up the fuel
surcharge on tickets seems to go up in
proportion or maybe even above and
beyond what one might imagine it should
but then you never hear about oh the
cost of the tickets is now coming down
because oil prices are down right sort
of the idea that as the costs go up the
price of a ticket goes up but then it
never comes back down when the cost of
oil goes down is that perception
accurate or is it just that it doesn't
make headlines when the fuel surcharges
are coming down it's probably the truth
is probably in the middle of there there
is always in commodity markets a concept
of rising like a rocket and dropping
like a feather right so you you see a
little problem on an oil market and
suddenly the price explodes but it takes
seven months for the price to lower back
to where it was when it comes to the jet
fuel and is obviously jet fuel has a lot
of similar problems to the gasoline and
oil manipulation as far as how exactly
it connects to prices for for flying
done that exact research but there is
definitely as you said a correlation
between it going up but not going down
when prices change so talk a little bit
about regulation around the manipulation
of prices I mean certainly the oil
companies would say no listen what what
people like Cody accused us of doing we
can't really do because of this
regulation and that regulation but is
there anything to that through that or
are those regulations basically designed
in a way where they can be circumvented
well actually we we have a number of
extremely strong regulations the problem
is there has been almost no interest by
federal or state regulators to do to
actually utilize the strong regulations
we have so in 2008 when gasoline prices
exploded to near $5 and some parts of
the country Obama President Obama
created a task force specifically to
look at gasoline prices and they were
never heard from again after the press
conference not that anything happened to
them but they never did another meeting
after the initial press conference and
actually the Federal Trade Commission
has regulations that are extremely
strong regarding energy regarding
wholesale trades for gasoline and oil
but the problem is they've actually
never even utilized on their own rule
that they invented so while there are
strong regulations I've always found
that the problem is regulators either
are too intimidated to actually use them
or there's such a barrier to beginning
to do this investigative work because
it's so expensive behind the data or
they don't know the industry well enough
that that really keeps the regulator's
from being from getting involved with
the election of President Trump this is
another huge problem because federal
regulators are the ones that should be
really looking at these these markets
but they're obviously completely
uninterested in doing so so that's when
the it kind of turns towards state
regulators and if you any Attorney
General in the United States any City
Attorney any district attorney or US
attorney could essentially try one of
these cases because these are very basic
commodity laws being violated it's
mostly just trying to actually
get a politician or an elected or you
know an appointed official could be
interested in doing the work
yeah really no political will to do it
is what it seems like Cody if people
have leads for you what's the best way
for people to get in touch well they can
reach out to me a number of ways that
there's a small network of people who
work on this investigative issue from
all across the world and the way to get
involved would be to email oil price
investigation at gmail.com would be the
best place for them to go we've been
speaking with Cody Rosenfield he's an
advocate and independent analyst who's
been investigating oil companies that
manipulate gas and oil prices currently
working with the Coalition for clean air
Cody thanks a lot for talking to us
about this yeah of course thank you for
having me